villains from 80s cartoons had a similar
sound you overgrown third coat you let
it get away
and there was a reason for that most
were voiced by this guy what alan
oppenheimer my name is alan oppenheimer
and i'm an actor
most famously he's the voice of falcore
from neverending story and skeletor from
he-man
why are you asking me these stupid
questions
get a life
regarding he-man masters of the universe
i was skeletor i figured the voice would
reverberate inside that bony head so
that's why he went up in here nasal
you boob you idiot why are you bothering
living
you've got a better life somewhere else
get out of my face
he did some other villainous voices
[Music]
there does seem to be some relation
there i stole from myself i mean hey if
i plagiarize myself you know no sue me
you know come in you royal boob but then
there was falcore
falcore was the luck dragon
he's kind and he's big and fuzzy my name
is falcor
and he's flying so you have that feel
whoa
let's go a trail
see
and he actually did a few other
characters from neverending story very
tasty oh i love
quartz is so tasty
get the picture
alan's had an amazing career
for me though
i like falcore
alan will you do the voice again
betray you get on my back and we'll fly
oh there are those bullies let's get
them
[Music]
okay
yes
you